this is naomi nagata of the ross
ante if you get this message please
re-transmit tell james holden i
am in control please re-transmit
after the fourth time she took the
length of steel springs she'd been using
as a knife and cut the transmitter
her false voice went dead the
acceleration gravity made her ankles and
wrists feel unstable
the air in her suit didn't feel stale or
close the carbon dioxide scrubbers
worked well enough on passive that she
wouldn't feel the panic of
asphyxiation she'd just gently pass out
and die
she popped the hatch open ripped off her
helmet and sank down
gasping her vision narrowed bright
sparkles filling in her peripheral
vision
she dry heaved once paused did it again
and let her body's weight sink deep into
the deck below her
tell james holden i'm in control for
some really broad definition of control
she thought
and laughed then coughed until her ribs
hurt even worse
then laughed again hey guys pete here
it's time to pick up where we left off
in my last breakdown video
and preview what might happen in episode
nine it's the penultimate episode of
season five
and things are lined up pretty closely
with where things were at the end of the
book nemesis games we'll look at where
the different characters are
some of the details that stand out and
seem important and just
generally speculate on those things
without delving into spoilers
that said if you're not caught up this
video will contain spoilers
if you haven't seen the expanse tv
series through season 5
episode 8 then this video won't be for
you i'll be talking about the books but
won't go
into any future spoilers there with all
that out of the way let's get started
episode 8 laid some foundational blocks
for half of the rossi's crew
in the way of character development and
it kind of leaned in the direction of
naomi's story with her being able to
alter the message at the end
in an attempt to warn alex and holden
about trying to approach the chetsamoka
based on that and the fact that the
episode is titled winnipesaukee
i'm guessing episode 9 will lean the
other direction
towards amos with eric on board to help
their little group there should be on
their way to new hampshire
looking for a ride off the planet
clarissa said the island was
private enclaves for wealthy people
vacation houses that are mostly empty
with their own hangars with shuttles
that they might be able to get to luna
with
based on everything we've seen this
seems like the right plan
there's this helicopter thing in the
background of the eric scene
and i can't think of a reason why they
would put that there if they weren't
going to use it to get out of town
if that's the case then getting there
might be the easiest part of the plan
because if we think about how they got
to this point clarissa
is technically serving a life sentence
amos is not
amos's real name his identity's fake
that's how he got off earth in the first
place
eric is the leader of a criminal gang so
they have to operate
outside of the normal relief channels
they can't just go to a rescue camp or
something along those lines
in a lot of ways their predicament
mirrors what naomi's going through they
don't have a lot to work with
and even if they can make it to luna
what happens then we know that at least
baltimore and new york city are
underwater that would mean that you
would imagine a lot of people are
heading towards the moon
rich people especially and amos eric and
peaches are planning on there being a
shuttle when they get to this place
so we'll have to wait and see what's
left by the time they get there
i do expect that we'll see that get
wrapped up without giving away too much
of what happens at the end of the book
i would just say that it seems more
likely that we will wrap up amos's trip
to
earth before we see what happens with
the chetsumoka
there it feels like naomi's mostly out
of options the small victory she won
took a lot out of her
and she wasn't in great shape in the
first place after doing the hard vacuum
transit fighting against the
acceleration gravity scraping together
the few bits and pieces that were left
behind for tools
and then altering the message enough
that it would be noticeable
it's a colossal accomplishment so the
question is will it be enough
through coral and oxana we saw that when
they heard it they knew something was
going on
they believe naomi's dead so oxana
instantly thought that maybe she was on
the ship
we can imagine that the razorback and
the rasanante will notice the change as
well but at this point they don't really
know anything about what's going on with
naomi
so it's hard to predict how they'll
react marco's plan was to send this
distress call from the chet's mocha
which he sent in the general direction
of the rasanante
remember no one knows where marco's at
at the moment but he knows where the
rostanante is
because he was watching as they were
closing into the zamaya
changing the message was all that she
could do but it's not an ideal solution
if you think about it from the
perspective of the rescuers
hearing the change makes you think that
there might be trouble
but that could just light a fire under
them making them feel more determined to
get there
and save her drummer would certainly
have a different reaction but she's got
corolla on her ship to keep her in line
to think about what we saw happen within
the drummer faction in the last episode
we saw that they were all having trouble
with this new arrangement working for
the free navy
but then they also had this moment with
the spilled water that served to remind
them about how much they care about each
other
drummer was having the most trouble even
before she found out that naomi was dead
and that set her into this rage spiral
where she's in her cabin by herself
drinking
before everything got crazy the last
thing we heard that they were supposed
to do was to meet up with the cereal
mall
and the koto and go to siri's station
drummer agreed to that and seem to be
following orders
but that was before she almost pulled
her gun and shot coral
on the bridge so if we just look at all
that we take all of that into account
drummer's hands are tied she entered
into this marriage
with this crew and one of their husbands
is on marco's ship for the time being i
think this means that she can't do
anything to crawl
because that would mean that her whole
family would have to say yeah well we
don't really care about that guy over
there because we need to get rid of her
they made the decision to follow the
free navy because they thought it was
their best chance at survival
even if you kill kerala in the short
term what's gonna stop marco from
chasing you down we saw them in the last
episode they were scavenging
the destroyed ships of one of the
factions that went against him
so it is kind of hard to see how drummer
gets herself out of this
oksana figuring out that naomi's on the
ship seems important but it's still hard
to see how they can move ahead to do
anything about
anything other than just do what the
free navy tells them to do
and as far as what marco himself is up
to that's a question as well the last
episode didn't really give much away
i mean he's gonna find out that naomi's
still alive too if coral knows about it
but he was going somewhere in the pella
when he separated from the chet's mocha
so that might not be his first priority
i did find it interesting that the ships
that he was sending drummers faction to
go meet with
were the serial mall in the koto in that
earlier scene in the last episode where
kerrall was listening to a message
and looking at the captain's chair we
heard that that was from the cereal mall
in the koto
and they're talking about them being
duster ships so these are martian ships
basically these two ships that they're
supposed to be going to meet with are
similar to the rasanante which makes you
think that they could just take drummer
out if they needed to
but as far as what marco's up to himself
i'm not sure
i can't say that i caught anything that
would definitely make me know where he's
going or what he's doing
i'd be interested to hear what you guys
think about that in the comments
because i'm sure he's up to something on
luna we know that the new acting
secretary general
is courting the idea of destroying
palestine avasarala laid out some good
reasons to not do that
mainly that it would fuel radicalization
and make more people flock to the free
navy for protection
and on the other side of things admiral
delgado gave him a fiery talk
laying out some reasons why he thinks
they should wipe out the station
it certainly seems like pastor is
interested in doing something to strike
back at the belt
in his office he's reading what looks
like attack scenarios on his hand
terminal
as delgado comes in to talk and he asked
delgado to come there
i'm not sure who all the people at the
war meeting table were but there seems
to be a split between the diplomats and
the military officers
you can kind of see where they're all
coming from you can kind of see why they
would fall
out in the way that they did killing
civilians is bad
but marco did start the conflict by
doing exactly that
based on what we've seen it's hard to
say which way he'll go
but both delgado and avasarala made
well-articulated passionate cases and it
seems to me that the secretary general
is leaning towards delgado based on the
timing of things and that last meeting
and i think that's about all there is to
discuss there are some unanswered
questions going on
what happened to the proto-molecule
sample was it on that torpedo that
looked to be burning away from the
zamaya
i mentioned that i thought monica was
thinking about something maybe she'll go
back and check the battle logs and see
that one of the torpedoes took off we
haven't really heard anything about mars
when the rocks hit we heard that their
parliament building was attacked but we
haven't really had any follow-up on that
we did hear abu sarala say that they
couldn't be trusted she knows that the
free navy is flying around in martian
ships but hopefully we'll get some more
of that soon
i'm interested to hear your speculation
so let me know in the comments
if you're going to use book spoilers
please mark them we don't want anyone
who's not read the books to get spoiled
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon